Always with minerals and pretty sure I made a video
on a blog post about this really important
with minerals as you take the minerals,
the way they are key-lated.
So a mineral has to be key-lated.
You want to be taking minerals
the way they're key-lated in nature by God
or us to consume.
We were made to consume vegetables that have minerals in it.
So where do you get your minerals?
You get your minerals through your vegetables.
So it hurts me.
It hurts my brain when I hear things like this on social media.
You should use cast-ired pants
because that's a great way to get extra iron.
No, that isn't a great way to get extra iron.
We were not created to be able to digest
and absorb elemental iron like that.
So that is not a good form of iron.
So you want iron from a plant source.
Now you want minerals from a plant source.
Well, I'm not supposed to get a plant source.
I mean, I can't get what I need from a plant source.
Well, then you get it the way it would be in a plant.
So a plant takes minerals from the soil.
It takes like, let's use calcium.
It takes calcium carbonate, which is limestone in the soil.
And it converts it to a different form of calcium
that is easily absorbed and digested and absorbed
for the correct order by humans.
And it's keylated in a way with a double bond
to an amino acid.
So any good sample of a good reputable supplement company
that sells minerals or a multiple complex
is going to have the minerals in that form
with a double bond to an amino acid.
So like our iron that we sell,
all forms of the iron that we sell,
I think we have three different types of iron is ironed.
That is double bonded to glycine, I think,
which is an amino acid.
All the minerals that we sell are double bonded,
most of them took glycine, double bonded to an amino acid.
There's a company that makes for the powdered minerals.
That can sell it to some of the companies.
There's two companies.
I think they're actually sister companies.
What is called tracks and what is called albion.
And they make those minerals and sell it.
They don't sell directly.
They sell it to supplement companies.
So I always want to get minerals that are double bonded to an amino acid.
And that's one of the ways that you can tell if you're going to
have a crappy supplement,
isn't it sell, sell, says calcium carbonate.
Now, there will be some calcium,
a little bit of calcium carbonate in that that's actually occurring
in some things.
But when that's the form of calcium is calcium carbonate,
or magnesium carbonate,
it's literally just washed limestone.
That's you're just eating dirt.
That's not how we're supposed to get our minerals.
We're not supposed to eat dirt.
Plants eat dirt.
We're not supposed to convert it to the form that we eat plants.
So that's why you should eat animals that eat plants.
And, and eat organic plants, if at all possible.
So, and that's why, you know, grass fed beef is even better.
The grade fed beef because you're getting the,
you're getting Omega's from that as well.
Just understanding minerals and understanding food.